it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr isaac bogash who is an
infectious diseases physician and
scientist based out of the university of
toronto and toronto general hospital
uh it's so great to have you back on
today thanks for having me back on great
to see you again david
so we could start in many different
places i mean let's just start with an
overview we're starting to see
vaccination accelerate
in a lot of different places we're
seeing it in canada
the united states europe seems to be
about five and a half six weeks behind
where the united states is
and other places as well cases are
starting to decline
globally and then certainly much more
precipitously in some particular
countries
the big question everybody has is is is
this the end and if so the end of what
right and
is this going to go from being pandemic
to seasonal
what's like the big picture assessment
right now
i think the big picture assessment is as
you point out some places are much
farther along than others united kingdom
israel the united states are
clearly far ahead you see cases
plummeting you see
life slowly and in some places not so
slowly returning
back to normal the rest of the world is
either a few months behind or sadly
sadly a year to a year and a half to
even two years behind
it's going to take a while i really hope
the countries that are further along
start to look more globally
start to think more about low-income
countries and low-middle-income
countries around the world that just
don't have the same access to vaccines
i hope we start to pour tons of time
tons of energy tons of resources tons of
vaccines
vaccines into the kovacs program to
really help
from a global equity standpoint help
vaccinate those less fortunate than us
but uh you know in general in general i
do
see the pendulum slowly from a global
standpoint
shifting toward things getting better
you know cases are starting to drop in
some of the more hybrid areas like
brazil and india they're still a long
way away from where they need to be
but at least they might be heading in
the right direction and you know quite
frankly
vaccines are here like we're in the
vaccine era we now have
tools to prevent this to prevent people
from getting sick to bring people from
dying we just have to get
we have to mass produce those and get
those all over the world which is you
know easy to say but actually
hard to do one of the common questions
maybe the biggest question right
now around vaccines is what about the
variants and we've had
the british variant south african
brazilian new york california india
from what i've been reading the current
major variants
are all the way i am reading it is well
enough
handled by the current vaccines doesn't
mean there's no escape
versus the sort of original uh
you know live version for which the
vaccines were made but that if we
vaccinate
quickly enough these vaccines are good
enough is that your understanding
yeah i see it the same way too basically
if we think about the first generation
vaccines that we have
again in the united states canada and
europe
they're they're either really really
good
or good enough and that's fine because
quite frankly if you can turn a
potentially lethal infection
into the sniffles you're doing something
right right you don't have
the same public health emergency that
you would have when
you know a virus runs the virus runs
unchecked and
obviously preys upon everybody but
really significantly on
those on the older end of the spectrum
are people with underlying medical
conditions so
i think the vaccines that we have are
absolutely fantastic
obviously the the elephant in the room
is listen when you've got
unchecked transmission in some parts of
the world
there's always the concern that you may
develop
a virus that escapes the vaccine you
know and and we don't have that yet
right uh i have no idea if that will
happen
but that's that's the concern uh but we
don't have that
and uh quite frankly i think as you
point out the key message here is
vaccinate vaccinate vaccinate we just
have to roll these out to as many people
all over the planet as fast as possible
to get some degree of community level
protection
and again you don't have to have that
mythical herd immunity level you just
have to have
good rates in the community to really
slow this down you'll protect
individuals you'll protect populations
and that's the right path forward
i think the other point on this is we're
going to get a booster we all know it
they're already starting to make it the
boosters really start to account for
some of the variants of concern
probably something we're going to be
talking about either in very late 2021
or
early 2022. right but beyond that it's
not entirely clear
what the frequency of vaccines is going
to be but i think it's fair to say that
we get we're gonna get two doses now or
one with the johnson and johnson
and one at least one dose later on
hopefully that's it but there may be
more
so last time you were on we talked a
little bit about
masks and outdoor versus indoor and
i i if i recall correctly you and i seem
to be in agreement
not that my opinion matters as much as
yours but but from what i read
it seemed to go along with the things
you believe about
outside transmission is very very low
but we are team players and so when the
guidelines were
you wear a mask everywhere i was doing
it even on the bike path and so on and
so forth even if i didn't really think
that that was where where
a lot of the spread was we've since
found out
um dr ashish jha from brown published
something saying that pre-vaccine
maybe one out of a thousand cases was
being transmitted outdoors and that was
probably pretty obvious situations where
you're outdoors but doing something you
you probably
shouldn't be doing in the us the cdc has
since said
if you're vaccinated you don't really
need a mask outdoors then they've since
gone to if you're vaccinated really
you don't need a mask at all but follow
what your state says or follow what a
particular retailer says
things are different in canada for sure
some reactions have been
that new guidance is crazy kids aren't
vaccinated yet
the vaccines aren't 100 etc etcetera
what's your general reaction to the
speed with which the cdc has moved in
the us
uh listen i'm i'm a big fan of the
the new cdc under dr rafael wolinski
yeah i get that this is always going to
be a contentious issue people are going
to have
very strong opinions one way or another
but i tend to align with them right
i mean what what this is the point of
vaccines
right this is what they do and now
they're doing it they were supposed to
a prevent you from getting the infection
and b if you're unlucky enough to get
the infection
ensure that you have a very mild illness
and c
reduce the likelihood that if you're
unlucky enough to get the infection that
you transmit the infection
to others we do not live in a zero
risk world especially in the covet era
now you have these phenomenal vaccines
that are extremely effective
but of course they're not 100 perfect i
totally think that when you have a
significant degree
of vaccination in your community in this
case in the united states you know no of
course you don't have 100 uptake nor
will you ever get to that state but you
have a ton of people that have a first
dose you have a ton of people that have
a second dose you already have
excellent labs or not allowed that uh
trial data
and real world experience with these
vaccines
great i don't i mean i think it's very
reasonable if you're fully vaccinated
like
why do you need to wear a mask and then
what about the issue of of
kids right where if you're under nobody
under 12 has been vaccinated
they just started pfizer 12 plus
that's something i hear from parents who
say well i will keep wearing a mask
because the kids aren't vaccinated even
if
i am does that make sense scientifically
not really like let's think about it
it's this is goes beyond science and
more into value judgments
right if let's just think about this
critically if a parent is fully
vaccinated
okay you've got your two doses of i
don't know maduro or pfizer or something
like that
can you get the infection yes but it's
unlikely
if you're infected will you get really
sick no
but it's not impossible if you are
infected can you transmit it to your kid
it's always possible it's just very very
unlikely so
these are people's value judgments
that's totally totally
fine if people's risk threshold or risk
perception
uh is or risk tolerance is as such where
they feel that they still want to wear a
mask great i would
never shame or blame anyone from wearing
a mask
i think the whole point here is to
enable people to make informed decisions
for themselves
i think it's also fair to enable people
to say listen if you're fully vaccinated
here's the risks if you choose to not
wear a mask that's also okay too
we're in a bit of a wild west right now
right rapidly emerging data
rapidly uh uh you know vaccinating large
large segments of the population policy
has got to keep up with science and
and that means it's going to change
quickly with time
here's one that caught some people off
guard it's still a reasonable policy
but again there's no shaming there's no
blaming if you want to wear a mask
great if you want to take your mask off
great as long as you're making an
informed decision you're doing something
right the last
piece of this was in the u.s there's a
significant
anti-vaccine community which overlaps
with
donald trump voters at least for the
time being
and the concern was you know now that
the cdc said
vaccinated people don't need to wear
masks unvaccinated people will just lie
and not wear masks and the debate was
are they only putting themselves at risk
or are they putting
others at risk and it's really a
statistical question right
yeah i mean i think it's fair to say
they're putting themselves at risk
and of course they're putting others at
risk as well this is one of those
situations i i mean this with love and
respect like i really don't mean any ill
will toward anyone but
if we look at the look at the united
states and the situation there
vaccines are so widely available
to the point where some are even being
discarded right
if you're any walk of life it's
available like it's in pharmacies it's
in doctor's offices if you go to the
emergency department
for an unrelated issue you'll get one on
the way out it's in the subway stations
like it's
they're everywhere okay we often talk
about equity in vaccine
allocation and distribution but like
it's true like the barriers to getting a
vaccine
are really really low for almost all
walks of life it's not perfect but it's
it's pretty clear that almost anyone can
get a vaccine so that's point one
point two is some people are going to
choose to get a vaccine some people are
going to choose not to get a vaccine
great
your choice your body muscle top but the
third point is
this is such a contagious infection
that people who choose not to get
vaccinated
your luck's going to run out eventually
right your luck's going to run out
there's just so much of this virus
everywhere
globally even in the united states like
people will
sadly get infected eventually if they
choose not to get vaccinated and again
i don't want i don't wish ill on anyone
but it's gonna reach a point where
you've said listen we've given everybody
ample opportunity to get a vaccine you
can change your mind you can get a
vaccine anywhere you want
you've chosen not to that's your choice
that's your decision but like
we know what happens like you don't you
don't need a crystal ball to look in the
future and see
that many of those individuals sadly who
are either on the either on the older
end of the spectrum or have medical
conditions
are going to get sick and land in
hospital and some of them are going to
die and
you know that's awful that's awful
because it's completely preventable
yeah one of the i mean i i've been
stressing to my audience
there are countries that have no
vaccines right now there are countries
that they get a shipment of a hundred
thousand
and they're thrilled with a hundred
thousand vaccines
we have so many vaccines in the united
states and increasingly in other
countries as well canada europe getting
more and more vaccines
and you know 40 percent of trump voters
just don't want to get one
it's almost insulting it's disgusting i
don't know what the right word to to
attach to it is
i mean it's it's it's perplexing
it's mind-boggling it's sad and and
you know sometimes you just stop start
blaming yourself like oh as a medical or
as a scientific or as a public health
community
we haven't done enough i mean obviously
it's more complicated than this right
this is truly going to be a struggle
moving forward i mean this first of all
this predated coven 19 and this will be
this issue will be along well after
copen 19 is
is an afterthought but we really
have to fight a better fight on
social media and in mainstream media and
in regular conversations
to enable people to make appropriate
decisions for themselves based on
data fact logic science
right like i listen i truly am all for
people making individual decisions for
themselves i would never want to
coerce people i would never want to
counterbalance
extreme misinformation against vaccines
with extreme misinformation on the other
side of the spectrum
just be honest just present the data in
a meaningful
digestible manner and the key here is
communication
in an age language and culturally
appropriate manner that's easily
digestible
but again i mean look what we're up
against we're up against
you know social media which does i know
they say they're trying to
combat this misinformation but like it's
a huge failure
uh we're up against you know people who
dig in their heels
and and cultural norms like this is
going to be a an uphill battle and sadly
sadly lives are going to be lost and
it's not
an insignificant number of lives like
this is going to be measured in the
thousands and thousands or quite frankly
in the ten
thousands of lives probably even more i
mean there's half a million americans
died
right yeah half a million people died
from this and how many more are gonna
die
uh because of misinformation and
pseudoscience that's being amplified
online yeah and the real number it you
know officially six hundred thousand
probably in reality thirty to 40 percent
more it's probably close to a million
deaths
is the real number to follow up on a
couple of other things that when we last
spoke we were still learning about
the primary mode of transmission here in
terms of location we learned
outdoor is close to zero the bleaching
of the bananas and stuff like that that
was not
that was not prevent that was not a a
source of contagion
is it people indoors breathing on each
other is that really what this is
yes yes safe to say that the vast
majority of this infection is
transmitted
indoors with people in close contact
with each other can you still get this
infection
indoors while far away from other
someone else sure
sure you can there's you know tons of
case reports
and examples of this but primarily close
contact
indoors doesn't have to be for you know
that magic number of 15 minutes
you can have a high exposure fleeting
contact uh you know it's gross to think
about but if someone like cost in your
face
indoors you're gonna get this infection
even if it's for a second
yeah indoor like it's safe to say you
know to oversimplify it
indoor safe outdoor sorry outdoor safe
indoor not safe this is it's basically
as easy as that and and you know
policy can align with that you know
ventilate indoor spaces put on a mask
indoors
pretty straightforward stuff and it
seems that the x factor for indoors from
some studies i've read really seems to
be the type of ventilation that you have
these situations where even with larger
distances between people
certain types of ventilation that that
are basically moving the virus around
can lead to people 20 feet away actually
getting it
but that that again we're now starting
to slice and dice
even smaller sort of situations i agree
completely i i mean
you can get this infection indoors it's
primarily indoors
i mean distance certainly helps it does
you can't ignore the fact that distance
helps that masks help
but most of this virus appears to be
transmitted
indoors in close contact with with one
another
um mass will help ventilation will help
but uh but you know at the end of the
day like let's just get vaccinated
that's that's really our ticket out of
this you know we're not supposed to say
there's a silver bullet but there is
the vaccines are the silver bullet like
right that is
protecting people protecting communities
it's
phenomenal to watch some of the real
world data emerge from places in the
united states from
israel from the united kingdom where you
just vaccinate a significant proportion
of your population you follow up with a
second dose
and you watch cases plummet like it's
just
remarkable it's remarkable and you know
when we're talking about respiratory
viral infection
i i'm fully aware that this is not the
flu but often we ought we will say well
let's look at influenza vaccines and you
know influenza vaccines are
like they're come seek himself i mean
but but like
they don't have effectiveness they're
not like 95
effective right now sometimes you know
20 30 40 50
effective depending on the year you've
got copen 19 vaccines that are like
90 percent effective for a contagious
respiratory virus like that's remarkable
like it's incredible they really are
transformed oh my god it's amazing and
the fact that
you know we're some people are saying
well this vaccine is you know
94 and this one was 92 like it's
ridiculous like they're
we're talking about vaccines that are
you know over 60
effective for a contagious respiratory
virus that's remarkable in and of itself
so
these are these are incredible vaccines
and they truly are transforming
the pandemic yeah even i was just
reading today about the possibility now
of an mrna based flu vaccine which could
also be a game changer on those you know
20 to 20 to 50
numbers it's really incredible uh we've
been speaking with dr
isaac bogosh who's an infectious disease
physician and scientist based out of the
university of toronto
and toronto general hospital always
great catching up with you thank you
my pleasure have a great day